good evening thank you very much about
45 years ago I think approximately Eli
and myself I just met Elias Sergio let
me just cast him and the good the bad
and the ugly and we went over to Spain
and went to all these wonderful towns
like Burgos and quarter Rubeus and we
filmed it all these places we we
actually had that kind of bizarre twist
we actually got to live the sequence the
famous joke of the CB DeMille you know
what that none of the cameras work and
it's any time you're ready CB we
actually lived that part really well
they blew up a whole bridge and
Covarrubias and and all the logs went
down and the rocks were tearing out the
back of cars and not one camera worked
then we went to a Maria which was not
such easy to get to in those days and we
would sit out and the evenings on
overlooking the Mediterranean and talk
about movies and plays and and and
politics and girls that we loved
Anne's name came up frequently because
she's the only girl that he ever loved
so there we were and I just want to
thank the governor's the Academy for
this this honoring this great former and
a great friend and I he's one of the
only he's one of the only living cast
members from babydoll and he's one of
the only living cast members from
misfits and fortunately he's one of two
living of the good the bad and the other
self
I'd like
so again again Academy governors for
your good taste and good senses thank
you very much
Eli would you can you come up here
you